all right what's up andrew
hey what's up how you doing rich good so
you're going through a divorce
man i'm going through a divorce and um
i heard you on andrew clavin
and uh like literally at the perfect
timing um
let me close this door real quick i'm
actually surprised that i that i got you
over from andrew clavin his audience
seems like super trot con i wasn't sure
a lot of people like that talk
yeah yeah i heard i heard you randomly
on there
and uh the stuff that you were saying
really
connected with me at that time because
my my uh
my girl told me she said uh
a month after
we get married she tells me i love you
but i'm not in love with you
and
basically um going through a divorce
spinning plates
read your book listen to your book on
audible a couple times got into uh
rolo's book and uh all that stuff's been
really helping me a lot but
like now that i'm doing that
like there's this there's this chick at
work i guess you've been into me
and um
like the sex is ten times a hundred
times better than with my you know my
ex-wife because she's got that genuine
burning desire she's like 20 years old
i'm 35. yeah girlfriend's always better
than wives yeah but um
okay so you got one itis for all right i
don't have one either for her yet but i
just find myself like wanting to hang
out with her and i have other plates but
they're just not as hot
and
i
like my attention is more towards this
girl so i don't want the same [ __ ] to
happen again
are you are you divorced like is the ink
on the paper are you done
no um i'm not i'm not completely done
yet i literally i just have to we did
like a no uh contest divorce so you
don't have any kids or anything though
right no i have a i have a daughter from
a previous relationship yeah but um why
did she get
why did she get married to you and then
say that she's not in love with you
after 30 days dude
we've been together for two years um
spent twenty thousand dollars on a
wedding uh you know i i still have a
hundred and sixteen dollars left on my
on the engagement ring paying it off
over 18 months um and
literally i i i boggled my mind like we
just bought this this this house
um six months ago beautiful house in um
you know nice area and
after
like three weeks after we get back from
the honeymoon she tells me um
i love you but i'm not in love with you
kind of got into a weird conversation
she tells me that come to find out i put
a i put a um i looked at her phone
record because we have the same phone
plan she's talking to this neighbor guy
and put a tracker on her car caught her
going to his house when she says she's
going somewhere else so like so she
started
you know by the way
that was that was going on before you
guys got married yes for sure it's not
likely that that just popped up after
you guys said i do and came back from
the honeymoon anyway okay so
so back to like not catching the feels
for a 20 year old thought
basically what we're talking about yeah
basically okay well let's let's start
with that i mean let's stop putting her
up on a pedestal and oh she's so pretty
and smells so nice and the sex is the
best ever right like let's let's just
you know admit that you're 35 and she's
a 20 year old thought right and you're
going through divorce you're not married
so why would you want to catch like
feels for you know something like that
like why would you expose yourself to
some new risk
yeah i know that's not a good idea at
all yeah so
so there's that there's also that you
don't have any other options right
because i mean you said that she's a
plate and that you're seeing some other
girls but the other girls are not worthy
of any mention right right so you need
to move past the ones that you're not
attracted to just drop them
right okay you don't want to keep you
know moons in orbit around you if
they're not
anything that you're interested in right
so let them go and you know
get on with you know checking out what
else is out there so that you can make
time in your schedule for some new women
that are potentially
as attractive or even more attractive
than the one that you're about to catch
the feels for
those will be the main things
i think you're well i know you're 100
right um
it's like it's like because i've been
like cooped up in this relationship and
um you know
like i never cheated on her or anything
like you know she's pretty hot too
but um
this is a girl from work too you said
right yeah yeah did she work under you
did she work in a different apartment uh
no well uh originally we worked in the
same department and then
we both kind of got promotions and so
she was in a different part and then um
and then she ended up getting a really
good promotion you know what's so crazy
all the [ __ ] that you talk about in the
book um and rolo um like when a woman
starts to make when a woman starts going
to the gym and when she uh gets a raise
or a promotion at work
um then it's more likely that she's
going to leave she started making
like double as double the amount of
money i made she made well i made 100
and five thousand last year wait are you
talking about your ex-wife are you
talking yeah the ex-wife oh you're
talking about the ex-wife now okay yeah
i'm just like on a side note like uh all
that it's crazy how every single thing
in the book is like exactly accurate
which is why i continue to watch your
videos and and read
but i'm glad i was able to help you out
and yeah and i and you found me off the
andrew clavin show so that's kind of
cool
yeah honestly um the part because um and
now this is also on the side note the
part that you said when um you know your
intro when you talked about um you were
driving in your truck and the thought
went into your head of just like taking
your seatbelt off
that exact thought went through my head
and i connected with that right away and
just thought like man you know what
this is really helping me out a lot so i
really appreciate what you do
do me a favor then if you if you got
that much value out of the book leave a
written review on amazon and let other
guys know you know what you learned from
it i will do that i hear you say that
all the time and i haven't done it i
will do that please do it yeah yeah that
because that cause that helps me out and
helps other guys understand that there's
some value in the book because there's
always trolls and nerds that are like
this is misogynistic yeah
all right so so there's your answer to
that you know just just spin more plates
yeah and just get rid of the ones that
are holding you back you know anchors
and sales right you know so so if the
rankers you're not interested cut the
anchors loose and let go of them and uh
you know throw up some new sails and see
what you can find question just one last
question do you just ghost him
i wouldn't go somebody just say hey yo
well it depends like is it a week or two
ghost them right i mean if you've been
dating for like a few months just say
hey you know what i just don't really
dig your vibe so there's no point in
wasting each other's time
sick okay yeah perfect
simple i appreciate you taking taking my
uh my my answer my question all right
andrew thanks man all right man see bro
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you